hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday May 4th 2020 what's going on how
are you May fourth everybody we are 11
days away from this whole thing just oh
I know that's true cuz old Donny boy
said it was gonna happen
Donny boy Donny boy yeah that I did at
dah dah dah
he says it's all opening up on May 15th
which totally makes sense do you know if
he'll reopens it and everybody gets sick
the fact that he's gonna get [ __ ] for
that when I am still I'm taking my daily
walk my old man walk old shuffling down
the street like some old [ __ ] mob
boss you know who's trying to pretend
he's insane you know I don't have the
bathrobe on but I definitely got the
mask and all of that [ __ ] right I go out
to the grocery still I wait my turn to
go in I got the gloves I got the mask
right looking like a [ __ ] beak right
but there's just too many selfish
[ __ ] [ __ ] I see yesterday I'm
walking down the street by do but Boop I
might have my business and across the
street I see I'm assuming a husband and
a wife life partners I don't know what
terminal one-night-standers across the
street both pushing strollers with like
a one-year-old and a three-year-old or
something like that right adorable kids
beautiful family nobody's wearing masks
just walking down the street you know I
think selfish [ __ ] like that they just
like well everybody else is wearing a
mask
I feel fine so I'm fine I'm not doing
like the mask rule is for somebody else
so just I'm just gonna put this out
there as much as I don't like old
Donnybrook and I think he's a [ __ ]
disaster and he is a [ __ ] disaster
and I will debate anybody who still
supports still anybody who can debate a
guy
who's running your country that
suggested you shoot household cleaners
into your body you know something I'm
sick of hearing from the painters why
did I stir up a beehive with that one
and you should hear the what they're
talking about how many hours they work
and their [ __ ] city of you you would
think that they're actually out there
fighting a war the way they're waxing
about what it's like to color in a
[ __ ] wall
I'm sorry people I just have to I just
have to you know I just have to keep
[ __ ] picking on them not cuz I really
give a [ __ ] about painters it's just
that there's nothing going on in the
world everybody's just sitting at home
and I have no guests and I have to keep
talking so what I'm gonna do this is
gonna be the last day is each what I'm
gonna do is each letter for every two
weeks during this I'm gonna pick a
vocation and I'm just gonna [ __ ] on it
if there's if there's a job out there if
there is a job out there that you don't
like that just bugs you anything from
Jiffy Lube to [ __ ] inner-tubes
whatever the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
whitewater rafting to [ __ ] skin
grafting why am i rhyming I don't know
why whatever the [ __ ] you want I will
[ __ ] on it I will [ __ ] all over it I
will show the profession no [ __ ]
respect and then I want people in the
profession I you know we've all had time
to sit at home right and [ __ ] look at
what we do okay and if you like me you
stop moving you stop running right and
you're just sitting at home and what
happened it's like The Tortoise and the
hare
oh the tortoise comes over the hill and
that's all your [ __ ] demons from your
childhood and they all catch up with you
right and then they surround you and
then you're just sitting in them and
you're just thinking like you know like
wow I thought I was an adult I thought I
left all of this behind I went to
therapy I talked it out I never think
about this [ __ ] and it's just like no no
it was just it was just on the other
side of that hill just waiting for you
to take a [ __ ] three-day three-week
whatever [ __ ] sabbatical and then
it's all coming back old Billy freckles
and I'm going I will [ __ ] all over it I
will [ __ ] over because I cannot the
[ __ ] joy I am getting from these
[ __ ] [ __ ] painters flipping out
like I really think they all suck a lot
of them do suck though so I tried to
move on past the angry shitty painters
out there I can't seem to do that I'm
trying to like how do you find a good
painter you know what I mean there has
to be like you're in the ear if you're a
painter can you tell just by like the
guy's advertisement is it word of mouth
how do you get a good [ __ ] painter we
actually had you know some people who
just came over and redid this couple of
closets here because you know one of the
final things in the old-ass house that I
bought that I am is I'm gonna die in
this house or I'm gonna sell it I'm
gonna lose a ton of [ __ ] money I have
a [ __ ] toilet in my house
that I swear to god the only way it will
flush is if you take a plunger and you
go what god dad dad dad like 50 [ __ ]
times and then put one one square of
toilet paper
anything beyond that and it just [ __ ]
taps out and I've had person after
person after person come over here and
try and figure it out and somebody
finally figured it out and what happened
was some [ __ ] Dudley do-it-yourself
guy came I must have done it and [ __ ]
it up and put the wrong size pipe I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but of
course it's on the top floor so they're
gonna have to what they would have to I
would have to literally leave my house
or whatever the [ __ ] it was go live in
the garage with the family while you
know this who's kidding who moves
kidding no this this seven day job ten
day job
turns into three months we all know that
that's what's gonna happen so whatever
so I'm dealing I'm trying to put that
off last but anyways they painters came
in they did a great job they didn't get
a blotch of paint anyway I know that
they know that there's some good ones
out there but you have to admit painters
okay
okay they just you know don't get you
[ __ ] overalls in a bunch here you
know this some really bad painters out
there I would actually say that a bad
painter is almost as bad almost as bad
as a bad comedian you know because at
least with a bad comedian there is
something funny about watching somebody
who sucks at doing stand-up if you can
get outside of just the fact they're not
funny then it's funny that's just a
situation that somebody has a microphone
and is holding a crowd captive for an
hour doing a job that they're not good
at it is [ __ ] hell and nobody can
really say it I guess you can hackle I
don't know I think it's funny anyway
moving on here yes so I just keep seeing
these people out there and you know I'm
one of those old school
I believe in rooting for the standing
president but like I said once he said
the household cleaner in your body it's
my actually know when he saw both sides
of a neo-nazi and and in people
protesting neo-nazis or whatever the
[ __ ] happened all I know is it neo-nazi
and his dodge [ __ ] challenger ran
over an innocent woman and killed her
and he's like well you know there's two
sides to every argument oh my god [ __ ]
this guy anyways but I know you guys
think of a Hollywood liberal unless you
live in a red state then you think I'm
uh no unless you live in a blue state
then you think I'm a trumped I don't
know I don't know what the [ __ ] it is or
maybe I'm just reading a couple emails
and acting like everybody thinks what
five [ __ ] psychos think maybe that's
what it is I have no idea so I was going
on my walk and I went by these this
lovely family acting like there wasn't a
pandemic I had everything I don't know
why I didn't just yell
them they were on the other side of
street like why aren't you guys wearing
masks do you want to this to last
forever
you can't do it cuz their kids are there
but seriously it's just say it's a
[ __ ] special you know they're you
know what I [ __ ] you know I tell you
what I [ __ ] hurt do you know like
when you when you're [ __ ] you're at
the airport right and something's going
on with your ticket and you're standing
in line and you're waiting your turn and
somebody's up there and they're talking
and they're talking and they're talking
you're thinking like how [ __ ] long
does this take
right cuz the end of the day is you
don't give a [ __ ] about the end result
of their [ __ ] you just want them to
get the [ __ ] out of the way so you can
go up there cuz you are the most
important person in the universe right
so you spent you stood in line selfish
as you are you stood in line and you
waited your [ __ ] turn and you walk up
there the bands playing the spotlight
comes on and it's your time to sing your
little song and in the middle of your
[ __ ] somebody comes walking up to
the counter on the side because they
just have a quick question whenever that
happens man or woman I had this this dis
fantasy and I actually ended up seeing
it years later in the movie once upon a
time in Hollywood you know when Brad
Pitt grabs that chick by the back of the
hair and [ __ ] repeatedly smashes her
face on the man that's what I want to do
to the person oh did you not see the
line you have to stand in the line to
get up I used to see now I just say
something I just look right and I go
buddy there's a line and you know what
those constitute they just ignore me and
then that makes me even more angry and
it's just like what happened to the
world with this guy get the old Sunday
punch right in the old [ __ ] kazoo um
oh shut up bill you're not gonna punch
anybody at an airport you're a
law-abiding [ __ ] [ __ ] yes I am
alright anyway that's why do I look at
these [ __ ] people with masks can
somebody start driving around and just
yelling at people who don't have mass on
just do it in a copy it doesn't apply to
you the wearing the mastic is for other
people my other favorite thing is the no
masked person who then walks in the
middle of the street I mean just get a
[ __ ] mad nah you gotta get a bandana
tie a t-shirt now I'm not doing that I'm
not doing that's inconvenient it makes
my face sweaty but I don't want to get
it so I'm not gonna walk by the other
people so instead I'm gonna walk in the
middle of the [ __ ] Street and make
somebody have to slow down and then
decide what level they're gonna push
their horn do I go with a peep I I
[ __ ] hate myself that the other day I
peeped at somebody I should have just
blasted the [ __ ] home but said get
out of the [ __ ] Road and put on a
mask you stupid [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] kills me is all of
these [ __ ] people out here they're
sitting there and they're [ __ ] moaning
and complaining the government isn't
doing this and the government isn't
doing that right and then you got like
there's like a third of the [ __ ]
people are outside walking around with
the [ __ ] masks on it's like a you and
our kiss do you want to like do you do
you want the whole [ __ ] thing the guy
I don't get it I don't get whatever
whatever move it on
all right let's get back to the matrix
did anybody watch the Jordan documentary
last night Laura still smoked when I
told another amazing couple episodes
thank God that thing came out now Jesus
Christ I didn't know that they had
footage of that that that scrimmage I
always heard about in the in the
Olympics in the 1992 Dream Team I felt
bad for Toni Kukoc - is it cuoco they
kept going cuckoo coach the whole time
you [ __ ] play in the NBA I thought
that's how they said it now I don't even
know how to say you know I'm sitting
there talking about how they shut him
down it's like yeah you shut him down
and then he also had like another ten of
the greatest players who ever played the
[ __ ] game he's playing for [ __ ]
Croatia you know
jeanny who did you decide to key in on
and I love that he came back in the next
game and he scored like 16 and had a
good game I thought that that was cool
and I also thought that that was what
made European basketball players great
that was the the the tipping point when
when the dream team came over there and
just essentially kicked everybody's ass
and embarrassed them you know athletes
are athletes no matter what what [ __ ]
world they're in and they want to
compete with the best and they don't
want to get embarrassed and I just
everybody was just like oh that's the
[ __ ] level and not only did they get
up to that level they ended up
surpassing it in a lot of areas becoming
all-stars in the NBA so I thought that
that was really cool you know all of a
sudden you had all these Dirk Nowitzki's
the 7-foot [ __ ] European dudes coming
in who could hit [ __ ] three-pointers
like they were they were a shooting
guard I all of that to the embarrassment
of playing the dream team and how bad
they kicked everybody who was the guy
who dunked the ball and then pelvic
pumped the [ __ ] Ethiopian guy away
like y AK Chua Lee remember when I
watched the dream team I thought the
whole thing was embarrassing
it wasn't competition it was yeah it was
like watching like [ __ ] fifth graders
play tackle football against first
graders and then standing over them
after they knocked him down like yeah
[ __ ] what like I actually didn't
watch a lot of it but the the dream team
scrimmage when it was like it all it was
like basically an all-star game where
people really tried and play defense and
all of that [ __ ] they tried on both ends
of the court right and at one point
during the game they called a foul I
don't know if it was on magic but it was
it was Jordan had the ball and then they
called the foul and I've never seen
magic his entire career I never saw
anybody get to him I never saw anybody
make him mad like I know he was like
super depressed in 84 when he lost to
the south
but he kind of got over it when he won
again in 85 and then 87 and 88 I think
he got past that but like to actually
see him get mad and take the ball and
throw it up into the upper deck to be
like wow
nobody in his entire career that I ever
saw got him that [ __ ] upset I don't
know maybe he was a little more free
with his emotions because there was
nobody there I don't know what but he
took the ball and just threw it into the
[ __ ] upper deck when they called that
foul it was just like wow I never saw
anybody get hello hey lovely ladies
what's going on hey how are you you're
gonna have dance class come over you got
to come closer to the microphone hung up
but look at your cute little outfit you
have a microphone and what do you do
with the microphone you sing Old Town
Road has Old Town Road go there you do
I'm gonna take my horse to the yo town
road I'm gonna ah feel that kick good
job buddy I'm talking about basketball
and there's people out there in the
world that paint houses and they're very
upset with me right now at least some of
them are the ones that don't have a
sense of humor I can't believe the lack
of sense of humor that painters have you
know it is I think they're getting so
bad mad cuz they know it's true on some
level why don't they realize I'm said
everybody gets put on on blast as you
kids say I'm joking around except for
you nah you don't get put on blast you
like what are you gonna show me
you gonna show me a new book I'm in the
middle of doing a show you wouldn't
realize it right now but I'm technically
in show business right now all right
bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye yeah all right
okay I just feel like there's a bunch of
angry [ __ ] painters sitting in vans
right now listening to this gone someday
someday he's gonna hire me and I'm gonna
make them I'm gonna do the best job ever
and I'm gonna ask if he likes it and
when he the second he's blown away I'm
gonna take out some red paint and say
[ __ ] you you red [ __ ] upon the wall I
[Laughter]
saw a really cool old Cadillac I saw a
69 [ __ ] Cadillac Eldorado I mean I
that's just a [ __ ] man's car parked on
the side of the road in need of some TLC
original the whole [ __ ] car was
original it was [ __ ] the body was
still straight still the original
hubcaps on it you know the paint just
from years of sitting in the Sun was
pretty faded and I needed a new top and
all of that but Jesus Christ is that a
[ __ ] beautiful car someday that's
gonna be my retirement car and they get
one of those [ __ ] drive around I made
fun of painters and it all came
crumbling down still been watching the
old NFL games trying to figure out what
happened before a Super Bowl I was
watching the Browns at the Bears and I
got to look this guy up again I have to
give this guy a proper shout-out let's
see here
they Bay had a running back the Bears
did what the [ __ ] is it number 44
Cleveland Browns what was this guy's
name and I was like man this guy's he's
playing incredible right come on come on
come on where is he
1969 there was his number right yeah and
about 44
Cleveland Brown rusty rusty rusty rust
r44 Leroy Kelly the guy like I look this
guy up I'm like man I never heard of
this guy
and listen to this I go make sure I get
I get his whole his whole thing down so
there's actually people talking like
this guy should be in the Hall of Fame
it's 70 274 yards back when you had to
hurt it
he was an NFL champion 1964 he was a
six-time Pro Bowler between 66 and 71 he
made it six years in a row
three-time first-team all-pro he won the
Burt Bell award which we all know he was
the Commissioner I believe before Pete
Rozelle and they had the the the the
Bert Bell Bowl which was the playoff
Bowl for third place in the NFL that we
all know happened from 1960 to 1969 now
7,000 274 yards average 4.2 yards per
carry had 74 touchdowns I feel like in
order to get into the Hall of Fame he
needed to get up until like 9,000 and
closer to 100 touchdowns it seems to be
how it was but like Leroy Kelley learn
your old NFL players pre-super Bowl even
though he played after the Super Bowl
era but he was also on the Browns and
they were just in a bad way in the 70s
I mean the Browns were just [ __ ] him
I mean they were [ __ ] amazing 40s 50s
60s they [ __ ] the bed in the 70s came
back with the the cardiac kids in the
80s it all went to hell
Art Modell left we all know the deal 95
Cleveland smartly retained the the
ownership of the name the Browns and
they're the only franchise that's had a
perfect season and then had a 0 and 16
season they went like 14 and oh one year
in like the late 40s when they were
still in the All American Football
Conference
and our football league whatever the
[ __ ] they called it before they joined
the NFL and then they went oh in 16 a
few years ago I've always liked the
Browns and family I had family baby I
had family out there so I relatives in
Cleveland and Detroit so I always had
that's how I became a University of
Michigan fan that's how you know I
always kind of like the Tigers the Lions
and let's see here who else I guess the
Red Wings to actually find out one of my
relatives he was like yeah I used to go
to Red Wing games I'm like when he goes
in the 1950s I'm like you saw Gordie
Howe he's like oh yeah oh yeah and it's
just like well you went you went to a
number of games so I imagined that you
you probably saw them play the Canadiens
there was only six there was only five
other teams so you basically saw
everybody oh yeah oh yeah I was there
the inception you know it's hilarious if
I [ __ ] went back in time in a time
machine
that's what I would do you know where
Tom Cruise would go back and try and
kill Hitler I would go back and try to
get a ticket to the [ __ ] Colts versus
the Giants in 1958 the greatest game
ever it's at 58 or 59 something like
that I would go to that I'd go try to go
to the game we're [ __ ] Willy Mays
caught the ball over his shoulder and
then just to see people like what their
reaction was like was in real time you
never know in real time how great
something is is something like is it
good something when it's when is great
people continue to talk about it and
then like the legend starts to like blur
like the myth starts to blur what
actually even happened like there's so
many plays that I remember now going
back and I remember this play and it was
just like it's way bigger in my head
a catch a run a hit or something like
that it's way bigger in my head and then
I go back and watch it like oh that was
it's still not a standard play but it's
way more standard than I had remembered
in my head which is true with a lot of
your childhood stuff it's bigger in your
head than what it actually was it's just
that you were a kid when it happened to
you so what was happening was your whole
world and then as you get older in your
world expands you realize it wasn't that
big a deal hopefully unless you never
talk about it then it's just sitting
there in your head and it's as big as a
[ __ ] mountain bill enough about you
and you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up
[ __ ] anyway so this is the last week
I'm gonna make fun of painters I'm just
gonna read their [ __ ] things I know
it's a [ __ ] cool job that's not a
cool job it's a [ __ ] hard job and I
know that there's very few people that
are really good at it and actually take
the [ __ ] time to do it right
you can say that about anything you can
say about comedians mechanics Isiah
Thomas that poor bastard the
competitiveness of him is what made him
go in that documentary it's like why
would you Isaiah Thomas knowing Michael
Jordan [ __ ] hates you and think
you're an [ __ ] and he has final cut
on a documentary why would you go in
there you should have been like yeah boy
Bill Laimbeer I bet they asked him means
I have a [ __ ] doing NES final cut
[ __ ] you I'm not doing it I gotta be
honest with you as much as it as a
Celtics fan I hated Bill Laimbeer I
[ __ ] loved that when they came at him
they said hey do you know all these
years later do you regret not shaking
the Bulls hands he goes now [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them when we want it they said we
weren't real champions
oh here's another reason why [ __ ]
[Music]
wine Larry probably didn't shake your
hand after after the thing not because
he was a sore loser which is always an
option maybe
shaky hand cuz she went publicly and
said if he wasn't white if he was a
black player he'd just be another player
there was no reason to say that you win
it you went ahead and you [ __ ] said
that right and I don't all of this [ __ ]
I just think it's [ __ ] hilarious how
much it seems nobody likes Isaiah Thomas
and eat any but the thing about him is
you listen to him the interviews and
he's smiling and he always just had that
that that great smile that just made him
seem like really approachable and this
great guy and then now you listen to all
these guys like oh wait this guy's like
a used car salesman he's charming the
[ __ ] basketball shorts off of me
while he sells me a [ __ ] Range Rover
sorry I had a buddy of mine used to work
on [ __ ] lemon laws and he told me he
goes dude those because I asked oh you
do lemon laws and he I go what car right
now what is the car you don't want he
goes Range Rovers all the [ __ ] time
all the [ __ ] time now granted this
was like ten years ago I'm not saying
they're not making him right now because
I had to be honest with you I always
loved that [ __ ] via that vehicle but
I liked him more back when they were
like four lunatic white people with like
childhood issues so they had to go to
Africa and shoot a rhinoceros you know
just to stay ahead of their own demons
it's like dude isn't it enough that you
have a [ __ ] gun you also have to get
in a [ __ ] SUV and drive all through
the [ __ ] jungle in a goddamn tank
[ __ ] rhinos like what the [ __ ] is
that it already doesn't know what you
are and then you go out there if from
like a hundred yards away you just well
hundred yards is actually impressed if I
don't wear whatever how far away you are
you just [ __ ] shoot this goddamn
[ __ ] I mean what is a rhino so
[ __ ] roided-up cow it's a small
dinosaur I don't know what it is I do
think it's hilarious that people think
if you take the horn and somehow like
put it in your [ __ ] tea in the
morning it's gonna make your dick harder
and there's still people doing that it's
like we have medicine for that just get
some viagra and leave the [ __ ] thing
alone you [ __ ] right I don't know anyway
let's get to the if you listen to this
podcast long enough you guys would
realize that I have all the solutions
for the world's problems and none for
myself policy genius everybody I think I
have to [ __ ] remind people to not
take this part this [ __ ] podcast so
goddamn seriously or maybe that's the
fun of it that people actually do it
this is how bad my eyes are getting I
wrote cool old caddy as far as something
to talk about I have my little topics
here Michael Jordan parents no masks
cool old caddy and I just read that is
cool out and caddy like I'm at a golf
course and there's some cat caddy at the
golf course acting like an [ __ ] I had
that job I told you that I had that job
at a country club I [ __ ] I hated that
job only because I was a redhead but
other than that there was one of my
favorite [ __ ] jobs I have I had and I
loved all of the like I just thought the
members at at a country club I thought
it was the coolest [ __ ] thing ever I
could give a [ __ ] about golf but I just
loved the the ball breaking that they
did with each other I like that they
[ __ ] I used to like watching guys
[ __ ] with other guys at one time I was
caddying with this guy and there was
this other guy who was a better golfer
they're both good golfers but one guy
was just cool as a cucumber and that was
the guy I was caddying for and the other
guy was [ __ ] wound up like me and
they weren't even playing for money at
least they they didn't say it out in
front to us
right and I remember like he got in this
guy's [ __ ] head and the last [ __ ]
thing he did even I was just like Jesus
cry was getting on cough I thought there
was gonna be a fight this [ __ ] sweaty
wound-up guy right it was funny cuz the
other guy was older and he was in great
shape he was real
slim didn't barely sweated the whole
[ __ ] time he was just out there just
[ __ ] he knew like you know the thing
that fascinates me about golf is that
whole thing that you get in your own
[ __ ] head and then all of a sudden
you can't [ __ ] do it anymore
and the frustration of it I actually you
know all these years of making fun of
golf I now have a tremendous respect for
it basically because one time I did a
benefit and there was pro athletes there
and all of them said that those guys are
the best [ __ ] athletes out there and
I'm like what are you talking about man
you [ __ ] you played hockey you got a
lake when you learn how to run and walk
in here it's not the same thing he goes
man I would just go out there the ice I
was just reacting I didn't have did the
game is so fast enough time to think he
goes with golf you got all of that
[ __ ] time walking up to the [ __ ]
ball people watching you and you got all
this is a professional athlete said that
and as he was saying that there was two
other pearl athletes different sports
nodding their head and I had to sit
there and take a hard look at my gym
class recreational career and be like
you know I think these guys the chief
Dal it'll more in the the phys ed world
I'm gonna have to go with I'm gonna have
to go at these guys and they were just
saying how difficult the game was the
thing is I never gave a [ __ ] about it
and I always thought that hooking and
slicing was [ __ ] hilarious
and I would always whenever I played I
would go out and I would have like I
would have at least [ __ ] 12 just
shitty golf balls in my bag and it's
just like you want to look for that I
ain't [ __ ] walking in there looking
for it and another thing to it I would
count every [ __ ] that's a gimme no it
isn't no it is that's the thing that I
[ __ ] hated about golf was the amount
of [ __ ] cheating that's a breakfast
ball no that's not a breakfast ball I
already had my breakfast okay I had a I
had a nice nutritional breakfast and I
got up here and I hit the [ __ ] ball
and it's on two other it's too [ __ ]
fairways away
[Music]
I hit that I'm gonna take the penalty
how the [ __ ] am I gonna know where my
game is that if every time I'm out here
I'm getting graded on a [ __ ] curve
that's what I don't like about golf at
the the Country Club level but like when
you when you know what I like about it
at the pro level is there's no breakfast
ball although I will say I will say
watching somebody with a lead in one of
the majors completely [ __ ] unravel I
don't even know what to do I don't know
what to compare it to in sports how long
it takes how bad it is it's like it's
like watching somebody miss a kick to
win a [ __ ] championship field goal to
win a championship over and over and
over again so anyway so what we're I'm
Caty me I'm talking about back when I
was a caddy and I was a caddy oh yeah
the big thing is if he did doubles if he
had doubles then I would marry they
would pay you like ten bucks around 15
bucks for like plunk in 18 holes did you
just say fetch I'm not gonna lie you
literally you literally went and fetched
their clubs there was people in the
clubhouse that washed their clubs and
you know it was funny about that you
could always tell you could tell the
self-made men versus the people that
were born into wealth because the
self-made men always hung out talk to
you always made sure that they tipped
you well in the [ __ ] Richie Rich
people they were always like their whole
life they had like people who I don't
know servants or whatever and they would
come in and they they would hand you the
bag the clubs and they would not break
conversation with the other person
talking about their game and their
business of some movie and they would it
was like you weren't there
[Applause]
and the best was if there was a rich guy
with the self-made man and he would see
that and then when and then the rich guy
would see how the other guy behaved and
then he tried to KIII right die I really
appreciate it so anyway just keep
walking no they were tight [ __ ]
generally speaking they were tight [ __ ]
unless you you had there was a few cool
guys but there were there was a lot of
tight [ __ ]
yeah they had they had reputations - huh
yeah okay if you could just divorce
yourself from the wait country clubs
have treated your people it's actually I
love how you subtly this doesn't seem
like a cult getting over here everybody
knows what you were just doing their
country clubs is as far as being a guy
it's one of the greatest things you can
ever joint that's so much fun and it
beyond the golf yeah once you get
married and you have no free time and
all your shits in the garage when you
[ __ ] go down to the country club I'm
telling you I you know I got a but we
have a buddy of ours country club I went
down to his country club didn't even
play golf not that give a [ __ ] about
golf I hung out and just had a [ __ ]
rib tips [ __ ] sandwich and a couple
of drinks no I didn't have a dryad cigar
it was the best [ __ ] all they did was
just [ __ ] break each other's balls
you know they always act like it's a
bunch of white guys and they're like
carving up the country and I'm gonna
take tennis hey hey and you're gonna
have [ __ ] Wyoming it wasn't it was
just a bunch in the end I mean this in a
nice way a bunch of [ __ ] idiots just
a bunch of knuckleheads breaking ball
[ __ ] and Frank's gonna tell a story this
is gonna take 20 minutes or whatever
blah blah blah blah blah just I don't
know that was a bad example of breaking
balls but you know yeah yeah I
understand you're not open to no nice
I'm sorry no no I get it I guess I know
I I just say hey a nice day so anyway so
I'm caddy and for this guy and you know
it's a it's a foursome so it's I guess
it playing two against two
I don't know I I was always like you
know you handed in the club and then you
[ __ ] ran down to go spot the ball or
you were moving on to the next hole so I
don't know what the dynamic was going so
all I could tell was that the fats that
the pudgy sweaty dude who was a really
good golfer and I actually think was
every bit if not better than the guy I
was caddying for but the guy I was with
he was the guy that was leaving with the
girl right he was he was the hero of the
movie all right you know and this other
guy was the guy who had to work like
twice as hard and perhaps of it was
because he was in his own way right so
we got up to what a [ __ ] hole was I
think it was 17 yeah it was 17 and we're
on the green and at this point the pudgy
guy he has man twitted man twit man tits
sweat under his man boobs he's got like
like he has armpit stains but they're
underneath his man boobs and he had a
striped shirt and it was like you know
it was the 80s so it was like bit fit
he's got his spare tire over his slacks
and he had all the gear and and oh wait
no he chipped in on the 17 he chipped in
out of the trap and it went in the
[ __ ] hole he was a really good golfer
but anyway I don't forget what [ __ ]
whole of us so he lines up a putt all
right and my guy is closer to the hole
so he's waiting ok so this guy is a
right-handed golfer so he's sitting
there and he lines up the putt and okay
and we're we're not behind him we're on
the side where he can see us
just standing there being quiet being
respectful the
second he hit the ball and he's watching
it rolled towards the hole the guy I was
caddying for starts walking over to his
ball and before this guy can see whether
it goes in the hole or not this guy
crossed in front of him I was right
there I was like there's gonna be a
fight and he literally dropped his
putter and looked looked at me like do
you [ __ ] believe this guy and I
walked by him like Isaiah walking by
Jordan way he kind of ducked it I didn't
know what to do but I don't know what it
was I found it [ __ ] hilarious how
upset he got but now all these years
later looking back at it it's like dude
you should have [ __ ] said something
that guy anyway
there's my little golf story let me read
some [ __ ] advertising here before I
get absolutely [ __ ] before I get
destroyed by that by the painters and
then I'm gonna just to let you know to
give you I'll do a little teaser here
like old-time radio
[ __ ] you you redheaded do-nothing
content I have to start thrashing more
[ __ ] vocations alright but I always
come around I've been thrashing golf for
years and now I you know granny they
took some three professional athletes at
the same time to say how great a game it
was how hard it was but that is one
thing about me okay you can call me a
ball bred headed do-nothing [ __ ] all you
want but I can be swag I am NOT going to
sit here and just be stubborn and
continue to say that painters are on the
lowest rung of the learning a trade it's
like you didn't know how to build
anything you couldn't get in the wall I
love how plumbers had a sense of humor
that I said they they grew up in
single-parent families they didn't have
enough food and they used to go
underneath the sink to try and find some
scraps
or whatever the [ __ ] I said they get one
[ __ ] email from a plumber these
painters man that's there a sensitive
[ __ ] crew
I think it's cuz they dress like nurses
you know they come in dressed all in
white if anything if anything I'm
getting out of this I'm getting more
fans in the plumbing and in carpentry
vocation I haven't gotten a couple of
those emails keep trashing those [ __ ]
guys all right policy genius there was
never a bad time to save money but now
more than ever finding smart ways to put
some cash back in your pocket can make a
big difference one way to do that is to
simply save on things you're already
paying for like home insurance if you
own a home we shopping your more home
insurance rates with policy genius could
save you a good chunk of change and the
best part is you barely need a little
lift a finger to do it motivate your
audience
okay now that offends me like I know
what I'm supposed to be doing here the
first thing I have to do is I have to
get them to listen to the copy that's
what I need to do first
all right you'd know that if you really
were a genius policy genius first head
to policy genius calm and answer a few
quick questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius will compare
your policy against options from top
insurers to make sure you're getting the
right home insurance coverage at the
best possible price if policy genius
finds you a better rate than what you're
currently paying they'll do all the work
to get you switched I mean come on man
I'm [ __ ] you don't do anything that's
perfect own a car - policy genius will
compare your home and auto policies
across different insurers and even
mix-and-match to find you savings they
save their customers an average of 1127
dollars per year just doing that
call-to-action parentheses this section
is mandatory if you write it I read it
buddy so or lady Bartley
so if you'd like to put a little cash
back in your pocket right now see how
much you can save
wait so if you'd like to put a little
cash back in your pocket right now see
how much you can save by reshaping your
home insurance rates at policy
genius.com I don't like how this there's
no sort of podcast code there how will
they know that I sent them there ah geez
alright HELOCs helix okay here is my
HELOCs Edie hello I'm Bill burr I'm a
really unique they're still doing this
[ __ ] copy I am NOT a real unique guy
that is not why you like my podcast you
like my podcast because you you listen
to me [ __ ] blow a gasket and then it
makes you feel better about yourself and
your own shortcomings I don't know
anyways the hallux is truly one of a
kind I guess next please mention all the
talking points below as I've said before
advertisers if you write it I will read
it
helix sleep built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preference to the perfect matrix
for you if you like a mattress that's
really soft or firm you sleep on your
side or your back or your stomach or you
sleep really hot gross
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and everybody's unique tastes
like you just go to HELOCs leap comm
slash bar b you are r take their
two-minute sleep boys and they'll match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life
that's it says like me after that I
think there's a joke there I don't know
what he'll expose even awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2019 by GQ & Wired magazine they have a
10 year warranty 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for a hundred nice
risks free they'll even pick it up if
you don't like it great I bet people are
all wearing masculine that goes down
anyways right now hellix is offering up
to $200 off mattress orders for our
listeners get up to $200 at helix calm /
bur prop ok + / / that's alright look at
you Nene looking good this
died all right there you go I think I
mean I have to double-check that that is
all the advertising for this week before
I get absolutely raked over the
proverbial coals by all of these these
[ __ ] irate painters I mean they are
so irate I am surprised that you know no
other no other websites have picked up
on how this controversy all right
prop painter from the mandalorian I did
an episode of that last season hey there
bill my day job as a prop painter for
movies and TV that's my day job of
congratulations that's a cool job I
mainly specialize in weapons I've worked
on a bunch of stuff you may recognize
from Avengers better call Saul Westworld
these are all my adventures I don't
watch i watch everything else and a lot
of the weapons and droids for the
Mandalorian you might be a little Stoke
to know I've made a lot of these things
while listening to the Monday morning
podcast as lucky as I have been to find
my way into having the honor to paint
some really cool stuff I started I
started out my painting career painting
houses in my college years I can't argue
with you that a majority of house
painters suck thank you validation
validation if you can compare it to
something like cooking painting houses
is like starting your cooking career at
a Denny's if you haven't moved on to a
better restaurant after a few years then
you're probably not going to do it for
the love of it or as a career choice if
you haven't moved on to industrial
painting cars murals or entertainment
then you're just doing it for the money
and you're most likely just trying to
bang jobs out then you're not doing and
not so much caring about the artistry
while painting another four walls some
off-white color all right that makes
sense so basically painting houses is
sort of the open mic of painting and
then you move on to more to like more
difficult stuff to paint right I'm
joking
I know that there's the Richard prize
and George Carlin's of house painters
I'm [ __ ] joking people relax all
right and by the way is there anything
cooler than someone who paints cars all
right I think that's that's [ __ ]
amazing and actually you know come on
some of the some of the the graffiti
that the people who suck at painting
paint over you know what I mean do you
ever have guilt people who just paint
walls when you paint over graffiti do
you ever look at the you have a stand
back and be like wow this this vandal is
actually better at what they do than I
am you know as your paint drips down
onto these poor plants underneath the
graffiti in defense of painters they
can't hide their shitty work the way a
plumber can like whoever did my old ass
[ __ ] house they can't hide they're
like I had a I had a guy coming over
looking at the hot-water heater the
other day and I have like one I don't
know anything about plumbing but my the
the where the water goes in the pipe
we'll just say is three-quarter inches
and where it comes out it's like a
quarter-inch and the guy before even a
Mariner open a wall he goes well I don't
know who did that but that is not up to
code and he as a plumber was saying that
you know most plumbers don't take the
time to do it right so I think in
general we can you know listen here's a
deal I mean a few guys [ __ ] [ __ ] on
comedians I'll laugh about it all
[ __ ] day long I love it comics [ __ ]
on other comics I don't give a [ __ ] I
didn't realize how precious the art of
painting was a house how sensitive
people are until this guy here [ __ ] you
you redheaded do-nothing [ __ ] by the way
you forgot the hyphen between do and
nothing just the way you missed that
corner when you painted the house you're
sloppy [ __ ]
all right stop bashing my [ __ ] career
this guy really comes with soccer-mom
energy I'm working 75 hour weeks to get
my wife and kid through this pad
demmick that has your pussy-ass stuck at
home look at this [ __ ] guy he paints
a house and all of a sudden he thinks he
can throw heads oh you're a tough guy
huh walking around with the Oshkosh but
gosh overalls let me ask you this on
your painter boots did you write right
and left so you'd put them on correctly
I'm coming right back at you buddy
it's your [ __ ] whining about your
[ __ ] work week just because you
people hire idiots doesn't make all
painters bad this this point has already
been made stop hiring dumbass you
[ __ ] morons I agree with that take
your mic out of your ass hilarious and
learn how to vet a contractor you bald
[ __ ] once again body shaming me I liked
your podcast until last week you're
gonna take your paintbrushes and go home
you're gonna go out go cry in your van
hey good luck to you buddy all the
[ __ ] people that I have [ __ ] on in
this podcast all of these [ __ ] people
I've [ __ ] on you've had no [ __ ]
problem with it whatsoever and all of a
sudden I come around to you and your
little pedophile [ __ ] van with your
splotchy [ __ ] paint and your [ __ ]
nice head of hair right and all of a
sudden now you're gonna leave well go
ahead go ahead and [ __ ] leave you
know what yeah I'm gonna do you a favor
leave here I'm gonna look up I'm gonna
find a painting podcast house that you
can listen to so you can feel like it's
a safe space house painting podcast here
we go I'm gonna give you the first one
podcast America's number on I why the
[ __ ] is it oh my god this is just a wide
open market podcast for painters paint
talk 2016 what do we got here podcast
for painters why listen to a podcast
finding podcast podcast for painters
painting and decorating contractor's of
America paint Edie you might want to
listen to that one because Edie's like
education contractor SEO pro
construction guide there you go buddy
there you go happy trails
I when you [ __ ] soccer-mom you look
at you [ __ ] getting you goddamn
[ __ ] painter panties in a bunch
thinking that I'm giving a [ __ ] that
you're walking away and with your soggy
[ __ ] painter sock squashing sloshing
around your red and winged boots all
right I work harder and deal with more
[ __ ] than you could ever imagine all
right time out what do you know about my
life you don't even think you think
that's working 75 at 5 hours a week is
impressive to me buddy just to remind
you I do two podcasts a week myself all
right I then do another one with Bert
Kreischer I also run a podcast network
and within the podcast network I produce
stand-up specials and TV shows and to do
those I have to go around town pitching
those things all right that's just one
little aspect then I also write produce
and act on an animated show called F
astre family
okay I got to put out 10 episodes do you
know how long it takes to make 10
episodes of an animated show it takes
about ten and a half months and then it
comes out and then you go right back to
do it all over again all right I also
just finished a [ __ ] movie script
that I've been working on for two
[ __ ] years I'm also with stand-up
comedian and put out a stand-up special
every two [ __ ] years so [ __ ] you and
your 75 hour work week go [ __ ] yourself
I want you to go do your 75 hour work
week in front of a bunch of white chicks
that are looking for you to say one
wrong thing at your job and then end
your career and cancel you so go [ __ ]
yourself
75 our [ __ ] work week coloring in
[ __ ] walls go [ __ ] yourself
I am so sick of [ __ ] people thinking
that they have the hardest [ __ ] job
and oh do you paint houses in the United
States of America
you don't I want you to do right now sir
I want you to look down and look at that
spare tire hanging over your [ __ ]
belt and realize that 90% of the world
will never
eat as much food in their life than you
eat in ten [ __ ] years so [ __ ] you
Jesus I am so [ __ ] sick when the you
know isn't it [ __ ] hilarious how like
all these [ __ ] people oh jesus is my
joy hey sweetheart how are you what's
that
can you close the door and don't listen
to dad say the bad words hey sweetheart
close the door hey hey hey close the
door buddy thank you thank you yeah
you're working 75 hours a week oh good
for [ __ ] you to get my wife and kid
through this pandemic what a [ __ ]
hero what we're all [ __ ] working
everybody's working how many hours work
is a doctor working take a [ __ ] joke
you [ __ ] uh [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this
guy all right
he works harder he has no idea like he
thinks I'm just sitting by a [ __ ]
[ __ ] pool right knock-knock jokes
windows get painted by the [ __ ]
homeowners and idiot nephews when you
were too cheap to hire a real contractor
I run a business
play drums and sing for a band and still
have time to take care of my family
without complaining about [ __ ] that I
don't have any idea about time out time
out you just [ __ ] with [ __ ] all
over the entertainment business saying
that I don't do anything go [ __ ]
yourself
and then do it again you read fuzzy
[ __ ] it's plural for some reason
maybe he was just joking I don't know
why this is another thing everybody I am
[ __ ] over listening to how hard
people [ __ ] work let me ask you guys
a question how annoying was it when I
just told you how hard I work and I'd
even tell you how many hours I thought
how many months how annoying was that
okay just know that when you do that you
sound just as [ __ ] annoying oh my god
I have to bust my ass every week to take
care of my family
who doesn't who doesn't you know let me
ask you this painter you tell me what
you can tell me what in your [ __ ]
career you go do show do you go shoot
what is this Showtime at the Apollo
surviving that of being a [ __ ] house
painter go [ __ ] yourself
please [ __ ] this is this is my thing
about all of this [ __ ] the this is for
all you out there who are going to be
successful in life
no this that no one is going to help you
you're gonna be all alone alright if it
involves going on the road you're gonna
get to beaten you're gonna intimately
know motel 6 super 8 and those are like
above the No Country for Old Men motels
that you're gonna stay in alright and
you're gonna do whatever it takes to get
there and you're gonna do the equivalent
of standing in a cafeteria of college
kids in the middle of the day who had no
idea that was gonna be a show and you're
gonna stand up there and [ __ ]
humiliate yourself and there's gonna be
nobody there to help you okay and if
your dream doesn't go doesn't come true
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] alright but
if it does come true then what's gonna
happen is everybody's gonna act like it
was given to you and you didn't work for
it and your life is just putting your
feet up and sitting courtside and
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] playing
grab-ass with people this is what I've
learned about super successful people
most of them have pools and very rarely
are they in them
[Laughter]
the geniuses in the world somehow have
that balance of money and free time what
I find with most people that become
really successful is what suffers is
their personal life which is which just
ends up being the most important thing
and a lot of times they lose everything
that they have and then they just have
this [ __ ] thing that they built so
you know I'm off this whole [ __ ]
painter stupid [ __ ] I know that guy was
probably just [ __ ] around anyways but
like that is that is the thing like that
I there's a few people in this business
that I really admire that figured out
how to do it the top the first two that
I think is Dave Chappelle and Joe Rogan
they figured out how to be super
successful and also still like have
their life is still theirs we're with
this business that I'm in you know you
spend your whole [ __ ] time trying to
get in trying to get in driving by the
studios it's right there and this is
giant wall and you're trying to do it
how do I do I go through the gate do I
climb over do I tunnel under how to [ __ ]
and then you get in there and what you
thought it was gonna be and what the
[ __ ] it really is like okay this is what
I've learned in my business is peep
writers editors and directors like my
job as is the performer is way [ __ ]
easier than that I've done writing on f
is for family and I just wrote a [ __ ]
script that [ __ ] is a [ __ ] nightmare
[ __ ] nightmare is far it's not
physically demanding but you come out of
there you're like you know my problem
with booze came out of sitting in a
writers room after two and a half
seasons of f is for family I would come
home fried
I would just start boozing that was my
solution to it I don't know this
probably all just sounds like like you
know oh this is all [ __ ] easy and
blah blah blah writing a script that
that would be fun that's that's I'll
tell you this that's what I thought
and I have a ridiculous amount of
respect for writers and editors gonna
sit there and go through your 58 [ __ ]
takes of East each set up trying to
figure out what's the best one that then
matches the other persons in the scenes
58 takes forget about the dinner scene
when there's [ __ ] ten [ __ ] actors
there you can [ __ ] have that job I'll
go back I would go back to [ __ ]
warehousing before I would [ __ ] sit
and even attempt to [ __ ] the mental
energy it takes to [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
so I'm alright so that's the end of the
painter [ __ ] I was just breaking ball so
you guys pick another [ __ ] job I'm
gonna [ __ ] all over and then hopefully
somebody else is going to get their
panties in a [ __ ] bunch and and take
that [ __ ] seriously like this guy here
he goes Netflix money rant dear bill
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ] burp please
don't ever refer to yourself as a
political lefty again why because you
said so in your tirade against the
painter that mentioned your Netflix
money now here's the great thing here
okay I never talked about the painters
money okay you don't talk about another
man's money you just don't do that
okay he crossed that [ __ ] line but
here's the deal because I'm making more
than the average [ __ ] painter all of
a sudden it becomes a tirade and I'm the
bad guy
right he said you sir you said I earned
every [ __ ] dime and I earned I've
ever earned in this business yeah that
is the truth my ship came in and go [ __ ]
yourself I have Netflix money and I'm
not giving you a drop of it yeah yeah
then that did not exist in a vacuum that
that guy brought that out of me and
you're gonna ignore all that and so here
we go
yes you worked hard for it oh thank you
thank you thank you for telling me what
I already know and
earned it and I'm in complete agreement
with you're off the rails unhinged
bald-headed rent it wasn't off the rails
it was totally warranted but damn you
sounded like a Republican to me no all
right now now from here on out this has
nothing to do with me this has to do
what goes what goes on in between this
guy's ears listen to this ridiculous
comparison you berate the air-quote
greedy bankers evidently they're not
greedy in corporations constantly who
are the bankers people like you and me
who are the corporations people like you
and me they're not like me I don't know
what you do okay I don't go out and
[ __ ] you know inflate the economy and
then take it and then take everybody's
[ __ ] retirement away telling my jokes
what I do on stage does not make a
[ __ ] World War two veteran spend the
last two years of his life eating
[ __ ] dog food because they can't
afford you know I what I do does not
make people upside down in their [ __ ]
house and take their American dream away
from them the [ __ ] are you talking about
I don't pollute the water supply I don't
create a nationwide drug epidemic by
coming up inventing synthetic heroin is
that what you're suggesting he goes why
don't you berate the eight out of ten
Americans that live paycheck to paycheck
because they have the newest iPhone that
Disney passed their booze cruise
vacations their new car etc I have I
have I've actually done that during this
pandemic where I've said that now that
you see that the government can't
[ __ ] help me help you please tell me
that you're gonna save [ __ ] money you
have to save [ __ ] money because at
the end of the day nobody's gonna help
you you're on your [ __ ] own I have
talked about that
anyways their new car et cetera
how about parading people that
constantly live above their means max
about their credit cards this is [ __ ]
I've talked about for years in the
podcast sir default on their payments
and on and on and on so basically you
don't give a [ __ ] that this guy question
the money that I've made after I took
this ridiculous chance that 90% of
people end up just being [ __ ] you
know out of the business and become like
a [ __ ] substitute teacher in their
40s all right [ __ ] all of that none of
that [ __ ] counts this guy brought up my
money which I would never bring up
anybody's [ __ ] money what the [ __ ]
you makin right unless you're a greedy
banker [ __ ] because then you've affected
every button to everybody else's dream I
don't know dude I don't know what your
point is here I think you're just mad
that I used you feel that I didn't yell
at the people that you wanted to yell at
so I think you should start your own
podcast there
the banks aren't making anyone max out
their credit cards and Apple isn't
making anyone buy their iPhone III would
they have been wait a second yes they
are yes they are
by having the upgrades fill up your
[ __ ] phone that they then go in and
take your phone and [ __ ] take all
your [ __ ] out and then they go and
resell it again in Southeast Asia or
whatever you're you're completely
ignoring that all of these the design
obsolescence of everything that you
[ __ ] buy and that they make it
cheaper to buy something newer rather
than have it [ __ ] repaired which
destroyed the repairman business and has
the [ __ ] ocean filled with old
flatscreen out-of-date [ __ ] TVs yeah
you're you're painting a very broad
brush here sir
you actually sound more Republican I
would say well whatever the [ __ ] that
means anyways if people don't want to
buy it
wait a second but like the people that
you fat shame they have no discipline
with food if if you if people want it
they buy it screw the financial
consequences then cry I can't pay my
rent two days into a shutdown all right
well you're painting with a broad brush
here which is what I did with the
painters No
pun intended [ __ ] around I agree with
a lot of that and I think if you're in
the middle class that you need to do
what like saving money as a lost art and
I agree with all of that but someone who
is born into [ __ ] poverty and
something you're ignoring racism sexism
homophobia all of this other all these
other social [ __ ] issues that can
cause somebody guess so I don't agree
with that so there's my lefty side buddy
this podcast isn't fun anymore dude come
on but you're supposed to be [ __ ]
around here ever even I feel like I'm
[ __ ] I got to sit here and defend
what it is that I'm [ __ ] doing here
no here's the thing I I don't I don't
get in I don't [ __ ] talk about
somebody's money and I don't begrudge
somebody if they if they made their
dream come true and I was joking about
that when I was watching everybody
getting mad at these celebrities that
were doing zoom things and everybody was
getting all into their feelings about
their [ __ ] giant kitchens acting as
though that if that actor or movie star
whatever if their dream didn't come true
that they would have come to their
rescue and help them out which you
wouldn't have so I don't know what the
[ __ ] problem is all right Jesus
Christ like this this is not fun anymore
guys you don't [ __ ] this I'm not gonna
make fun of vocations if this is what it
brings out of people I don't want to
have a podcast like this I just like
saying stupid [ __ ] all right
Biden bill I think it's crazy that you
tapped out of the news with all this
Biden [ __ ] yeah what's going on with
this stuff like there's something that
they're saying he needs to address
listening to all the me to people throw
this woman Tara Reid under the bus
because her story isn't believable Oh
somebody told me about this Tara Reid
said Joe Biden did something but because
Joe Biden is on the left and let's you
know who's kidding hotaru doesn't
actually have like a you know it has a
very volatile reputation put it that way
they are not listening to her yeah that
is [ __ ] up they believed in women who
accused I don't know what that I think
that's the judge guy because they didn't
want a Republican on the Supreme
I don't think that's 100 percent of
women but I think that's a hundred
percent of the ones that are listened to
I think that there is definitely a
double standard when it comes to that
Terry's mom called in Larry King in the
early 90s trying to get traction because
authorities refused to take action when
reported 30 years ago it's so
transparent but for some reason people
are playing dumb so hard what do you
mean people are playing dumb so hard
there's people that still think Donald
Trump should be reelected and he said
the shoot [ __ ] Drano basically into
your body this is what people do
politics is just like sports your team
cheats but my team doesn't that's past
interference and then when we do it
that's a good no-call people do that
with me too and they do it with politics
unfortunately selfishly I like that
they're doing it because it exposes the
fact that then that when it really comes
down to it they're they're into their
into their own whatever the [ __ ] it is
they want this is the most serious
podcast I've ever had and I don't like
it I don't like talking about this [ __ ]
anyways it's so transparent but for some
reason people are playing dumb so hard
progressives went after Joe Rogan for
dumb [ __ ] harder than a presidential
candidate who's the face of everything
they've hated yeah that's when Rogan
said that he was going to he supported
Bernie Sanders Biden gropes chicks all
right well that's still alleged it has
to be proven he was a huge part of the
crime bill in the 90s that imprisoned
one hundreds of thousands of black men
and classified them as super predators
and he has a consistent record of voting
for wars and staying in line with the
Democratic establishment mind blowing
stuff bill is it is any of that anything
that you wrote there surprising all
right the fact that Biden has a let's
just talk about the history of voting
for wars and staying in line with the
Democratic establishment that more than
anything is a reason why Hillary lost
and Trump won
all the theories out there it was I
think the 2000 this is my own [ __ ]
and I don't follow this stuff but I
really believe that the 2008 banking
crisis and the fact that the bankers
didn't go to jail the government bailed
out the banks and who's kidding who we
now have two people who are upside down
in the house had to help bail them out
after they got [ __ ] over and none of
them went to jail I think that Hillary
came along and was was a [ __ ] company
person was going to toe the company line
and that was not what people wanted and
Trump was saying what people wanted to
hear I'm gonna drain the swamp and I'm
gonna do this and I'm gonna do that and
all of this [ __ ] and that's what they
were looking for and they should have
put Bernie Sanders it was like a it was
like a prizefight it was just like it
wasn't a good matchup a better matchup
was another guy saying I'm gonna do
basically his way of saying I was gonna
drain the swamp on the left and you have
them go at it which I still believe that
the best matchup if you want Trump out
of there is you put the left version of
him so then it's like all right this is
this is gonna be a good fight I think
the Democrats once again for some reason
are going with the company man and III
think that's I definitely think that
that is of that is a [ __ ] error but
and this is why I usually end up voting
I should say always I mean since way
back way back those last time I voted
for an actual Democrat or Republican for
president I think in 96 I actually voted
for Bill Clinton and if I could go back
I wouldn't have because he was the guy
that signed the last thing for
deregulating banks as far as I know that
opened up what the [ __ ] ended up coming
to fruition in 2008
which of course George W Bush I mean
George yet George debía got blamed for
cuz it happened while he was president
which wasn't fair and that was basically
that thing that somehow made people not
qualified for houses qualified and then
you went from five people bidding on a
house to ten people and then they
artificially inflated the house because
the market you know it's basically a
supply and demand and when you make way
more people eligible for these loans the
demand goes through the roof so then the
price of the house goes up high and then
eventually those people who can't afford
the house it was it's like they they
just they just use them as warm bodies
in these houses and then something like
these loans that they gave them for that
they could afford the house for like a
year and then all of a sudden they
couldn't because then the payment jumped
up and then they had to sell and they
kicked it back on a plane eventually
they ran out of SAP's
I mean I know this is a very remedial of
what went down they ran out of SAP's and
the whole [ __ ] thing came crashing
down and then people who were qualified
ended up in a house that they paid way
more than what the [ __ ] it was worth and
I even got caught up in that [ __ ] on my
house when I went to go fix the [ __ ]
roof on my house when I had water damage
cuz they [ __ ] up the [ __ ] job and I
didn't want to deal with that I had
insurance and I'm not gonna go to court
with this guy [ __ ] it right when the
check came to me my insurance that I
paid for all the money I [ __ ] pay for
when the check came it was made out to
me and the bank that that owned my
mortgage and I had to sign it over to
them so they could make sure that that
money was going to be used to fix the
roof because what happened was they
[ __ ] so many people over and the house
wasn't worth what they owed on it when
they actually had an insurance claim
they didn't fix it they just kept the
money so they would have some money and
then when eventually they had to sell
the [ __ ] house the bank would get the
house back and then they had to
fix the roof and then they were upset
about that even though they created that
situation so I was so [ __ ] mad when I
called the bank I was like hey I pay my
bills you want to look at my [ __ ]
credit report I'm responsible with my
money you aren't and there was nothing I
could do and I had to send it over to
them and with each portion of the job I
had to wait for one of those [ __ ]
banker [ __ ] to come over and inspect
the job to make sure that it was done
coming over like a [ __ ] parent so I
think that that's what ended up making
that happen and as far as this guy's
money rent I 100% agree with if you're
maxing out your credit cards and you
live in week to week you are setting
yourself up okay and you aren't you are
a victim of your own foolish ways with
money and I'll forgive a younger person
but after you've learned the lesson they
just continually be living week to week
once you're making a certain amount of
money you and your wife there's no
reason to be living like that you bought
too much house you bought too much car
you bought too many [ __ ] Apple [ __ ]
and this guy is oh this woman is 100%
right about that however if you're below
the poverty line if you're dealing with
racism sexism and homophobia and all
that [ __ ] like that that becomes a
different variable that you definitely
have to look at so I don't know that
that's where this Jesus Christ this is I
feel like I'm [ __ ] the host and
[ __ ] Meet the Press right now I'm an
hour and 20 minutes in that's how
[ __ ] not guys I don't want to talk
about these giant [ __ ] issues all
right I have empathy for all you guys
including the [ __ ] painters I'm not
trying to get into this [ __ ] I'm
supposed to make you forget about your
problems not sit here and talk about it
so anyway it is a thing to just if
you're making a zillion dollars you can
still be that [ __ ] idiot who then you
know if you're making 10 million dollars
a year you can then be that idiot who
lives a lifestyle that requires you to
make 10 million dollars like I learned
that in this [ __ ] business I want I
watched people
I watched him get like back in the day
when it was you know the brass ring was
getting a [ __ ] sitcom I would watch
these guys
and women get these sitcoms and in their
first year they buy the big house they
get the [ __ ] fancy car and all of
that [ __ ]
and then I'll you know they weren't
getting ratings at bla bla bla bla bla
and they do a half a season or then
maybe they do like a season or two or
whatever they'd stop doing stand-up and
they would they would just [ __ ] they
would buy into this fantasy that they
had made it which they hadn't they took
a significant step towards it but their
ship hadn't come in and I would watch
them the show would go off the air and
then you'd hear that they had to move
out of their house and they'd always
keep the car because the car was what
everybody saw no one really saw the
house and then you'd see them try to
hang onto the car and then then the car
would be gone and then they'd be up at
the bar and then they would be like
super [ __ ] depressed because mentally
they allowed themselves to go to this
place that they weren't at yet they took
the [ __ ] ride and it was terrifying
and when I first got in this business I
would open with guys I would open forgot
I'm not gonna name names but I opened
for people that I remember had sitcoms
before I [ __ ] started in the business
and then like three years in you know
when I was in Boston they've come to
town they'd be back to and stand-up and
they were [ __ ] broke you guy was like
Hannibal Lecter I was looking at their
shoes remember this one guy came in boom
you know everybody used to wear the
white Reeboks you know his aerobic ones
and I saw like the creases in it with
the dirt in it I saw I tried to scrub
him clean I'm like this guy is [ __ ]
broke oh this woman is [ __ ] broke and
it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me and
I just I remember I talked to a
showrunner and with Patrice O'Neal then
we asked him and said hey when should
you buy the car and he's and this is
this was like doing math showbiz math 20
years ago and everything has [ __ ]
changed since then and he said I would
wait till after season three and you get
the
season four pick up and this was a super
conservative guy who was a showrunner on
three different shows and did not dress
like it and had a modest car and all of
that [ __ ] and I just gravitated towards
people like that's the guy that's the
guy that's the guy and if I learned
anything like that's you you always buy
a car underneath way underneath where
you're at you buy a house underneath
where you're at
and that's the way to go about it and
you save up your [ __ ] money cuz god
forbid something [ __ ] happens you
[ __ ] right that's why I drove a
[ __ ] Prius for ten goddamn years
getting gay bashed around Hollywood and
I [ __ ] love that car every time I
filled up the tank and it was like 28
bucks 30 bucks I [ __ ] loved it
alright so there you go so there's some
[ __ ] advice and I am NOT big-league
and anybody on this podcast I'm just
[ __ ] joking around so this this you
know I think just because it was a
pandemic people had less of a sense of
humor I apologize it's probably the
wrong time to pick on a [ __ ] vocation
I'm just [ __ ] around here people all
right I am a [ __ ] idiot
who accidentally got into the business
that I was in and somehow it all worked
out for me I don't know [ __ ] all right
there you go
all right you've still have a [ __ ]
problem with me then that's your issue
not mine
all right Johnny quest number one bill
you mentioned in the last podcast April
27 7th that you like the old-school
Johnny Quest
definitely loved it but I'm 32 so I only
saw reruns however there is another
newer animated show based on that that
ran on Adult Swim called venture
brothers definitely check it out oh you
know I when I was looking it up I
actually saw that I never seen it I saw
that it existed I should say definitely
check it out especially with all the
free time it's right up your alley
favorite character is definitely Brock
Samson and you'll see why immediately
all right I love the name already all
right number two hey Bill you recently
said in your podcast that you like
watching Johnny quest as a kid I was
wondering if you ever heard of this
cartoon show called
the venture this is another person the
Venture Brothers it's not for kids and
as a comedy while you are at home for
the quarantine maybe check it out the
show
is about what it would be like to grow
up with a life like Johnny but through
characters named rusty venture I would
go into more detail about the show but
that this would make the email longer
whatever dude I'm in I'm in I'm watching
it all right overrated underrated
overrated [ __ ] slow piano music in
commercials trying to empathize about
the virus I am so happy somebody else
got annoyed with you like is there
trying to sell me a car
we're here for you during these hard
times we'll bring the car right to your
house is that what you're gonna do
acting like you're gonna give me a break
in the price like you're not gonna roll
in into something out he said it reminds
me of Patrice's bit about white women
women singing to save puppies yeah as
always Patrice O'Neal ahead of his time
underrated reality TV cuz it's so fake
and off-the-wall that who [ __ ] cares
no soap opera could come up with this
virus [ __ ] I'm sure they could I mean
the movies have done it all right
overrated just hiring a jerk-off to
[ __ ] paint you have the room in your
house underrated doing the job to
actually find out who the best guy is or
lady to do the job there you go alright
Saul you paint it [ __ ] can quit yelling
at me and you'll have time to get some
turpentine and comb the [ __ ] speckles
of paint out of your pubes
alright go [ __ ] yourselves everybody
I'll check in on you on Thursday
I'm gonna I'm done with this [ __ ] I'm
gonna go back to talking about old time
[ __ ] football about when players had
day jobs during the offseason and when
the Giants played in the Yankee Stadium
and Sam Huff shared a locker with Mickey
Mantle all right I'd rather talk about
that [ __ ] all right then [ __ ] viruses
and people how much money that they make
see this is where this [ __ ] goes this is
where this [ __ ] goes when you [ __ ] sit
there and talk about people's jobs and
their money and I
so it's my fault all right and cue the
sad piano music alright go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday
you